bonjour à tous c'est théo de la chaîne
balladins mentale et aujourd'hui je suis
avec brut vous avez peut-être déjà
entendu parler d'un phénomène qui
revient chaque année sur certaines côtes
bretonnes au pied de la falaise baba
doit y avoir au moins 50 centimètres et
souvent elles font polémique
vous n'arrivez plus à gérer tout ça
qu'on fasse en sorte que ses allures
d'où vient-elle pourquoi sont-elles si
controversé aujourd'hui avec brut on va
vous décortiquer le phénomène des algues
vertes c'est des risques d'accident aigu
brutal soit cardiaque soit comme avoir
des scènes tout commence à la fin des
années 60 juillet ou de 68 en baie de
lannion et de saint-brieuc apparaissent
pour la première fois échoué sur les
plages des algues vertes des nappes
d'algues vertes en séchant au soleil
elle dégage une odeur pestilentielle qui
fait fuir les touristes
depuis cette date le phénomène a touché
progressivement de nouvelles zones et
aujourd'hui il est toujours en pleine
croissance
au début ces algues font surtout fuir
les touristes et à partir de ce moment
là certains vont s'intéresser à la cause
de leur prolifération
en 1988 après trois ans d'études deux
chercheurs de l'ifremer institut
français de recherche pour
l'exploitation de la mer pointe la
responsabilité des nitrates issus des
engrais agricoles et des élevages
porcins l'agriculture devient à cette
époque plus intensive en bretagne il ya
donc plus de nitrates dans les sols puis
dans les rivières et enfin dans les
océans et ce serait donc ces nitrates
qui serait la cause du développement
important des algues vertes
mais les conclusions ces deux chercheurs
ne font pas l'unanimité ils ont une
réaction face à eux très étrange
une réaction de gênes de silence et
finalement les élus leur ont dit que
c'était pas possible qu'il fallait
revoir ses conclusions et que d'après
leurs propres études faites en parallèle
les algues vertes serait plutôt lié au
post fatemi par les stations d'épuration
des villes
l'histoire continue quand en 1989 le
journal ouest france publie un article
les algues vertes ont peut-être tué
quelques jours plus tôt un joggeur de 26
ans a été retrouvé mort dans un amas
d'algues vertes
conduit à l'hôpital il est pris en
charge par pierre philippe un médecin
urgentiste
c'est alors la première fois qu'on parle
d'un danger toxiques des algues vertes
avec des conséquences possibles pour la
santé
pierre philippe l'urgentiste va ouvrir
la housse et il va se rendre compte que
il ne peut pas réaliser d'examen
tellement l'odeur est insupportable et
cette odeur elle n'est pas du tout liée
à l'état du corps qui sera en
putréfaction pas du tout le corps ephrem
et à l'état des algues dans lequel le
corps est englué et tout de suite il
pense que en fait ce jeune homme est
peut-être mort à cause de ce gaz
nauséabond qui se dégage de ces algues
et il va demander une autopsie dont il
n'aura jamais les résultats les années
passent et cet urgentiste va recenser
plusieurs morts suspectes et plusieurs
cas de d'évanouissement ou de coma il va
sans cesse se heurter à des murs rives a
sonné l alerte auprès de l' agence
régionale de santé - qui s'appelait à
l'époque la dass du centre antipoison de
rennes et il n'a pas de réponse il
insisté là on lui dit que comme y'a
jamais vraiment eu de cas recensés avant
peu là c'est pas vous on a pas de raison
suspecter que ce cas soit lié aux algues
vertes
bon là c'est le moment où on vous
explique pourquoi les algues vertes
peuvent se transformer en piège mortel
lorsqu elles sèchent les algues vertes
forme une croûte sous laquelle se
développent un gaz toxique l'hydrogène
sulfuré si ce gaz toxique libéré et donc
in aller à fortes doses il peut
entraîner une perte de connaissance
voire même la mort au fil des années
plusieurs intoxications potentiel
d'humains ou d'animaux sont signalés
mais aucune n'a jamais vraiment été
prises en compte
jusqu'en 2009 ou un cavalier évanoui et
son cheval mort sont retrouvés sur une
plage de saint michel en grève où ça
s'est passé en moins de 30 secondes j'ai
vu mon cheval qui arrêtait une ventilé
qui mouraient ménat extrêmement rapide
des mois dans la foulée je me suis
évanoui le cheval contient dans son
poumon un taux explosif d'hydrogène
sulfuré
face à la médiatisation de la sphère
quatre ministres se rendre sur le lieu
de l'accident
et pour la première fois la ministre de
l'environnement chantal jouanno déclare
publiquement
j'ai demandé des analyses aux
scientifiques et elle révèle que les
doses d'hydrogène sulfuré là où est mort
le cheval sont le double des doses
mortelles
et elle ajoute je suis étonné par le
nombre d'années pendant lesquelles on a
joué la politique de l'autruche il faut
que ça cesse il faut nettoyer les plages
et c'est ce que nous allons faire l'état
va prendre à sa charge financièrement le
nettoyage des plages qui sont les plus
touchés de manière ce qu'il n'y ait plus
de problème de santé publique
nous avons pris avec les agriculteurs
des engagements extrêmement précis de
réduction considérable des intrants
agricoles pour résoudre le problème
un plan algues vertes est donc annoncée
en 2009 il doit d'un côté permettent le
ramassage systématique des algues vertes
sur les plages pour éviter de nouvelles
intoxications et d'un autre côté en
s'attaquant à la source en réduisant les
rejets de nitrates par l'agriculture
deux ans plus tard en 2011 trente six
sangliers 5 ragondins et un blaireau son
découvert mort aux abords de l'estuaire
du gouessant et les algues vertes sont
de nouveau pointé du doigt seules des
analyses toxicologiques sur le sens sur
les poumons permettrait éventuellement
de mettre en évidence cette
responsabilité des algues vertes
alors que tous les éléments convergent
vers le fait que l'hydrogène sulfuré
soit bien la cause de ce décès collectif
comme le diront deux instituts
scientifiques linéraire l'ineris et lens
s l'administration et notamment la
préfecture des côtes-d'armor va sans
cesse mettre en doute
en fait ces conclusions scientifiques et
dire que on ne sait pas à quoi sont liés
c'est mort
c'est mort collective d'animaux pour se
défendre face à de nouvelles critiques
qui visent l'agriculture intensive
un syndicat agricole organisent alors un
match de foot sur une plage proche pour
prouver qu'il n'y a aucun risque
là
il n'y a aucun souci effectivement ici
ben là on est là il n'y a aucune odeur
il ya aucune pollution apparente
on a fait les efforts depuis 20 ans ça
va continuer mais on ne peut plus
accepter d'être pris pour le seul
responsable de tout ce qui se passe dans
cette bague les agriculteurs mais
surtout les décideurs économiques du
monde agricole les responsables de
l'agro alimentaires vont par différents
moyens essayer de maîtriser le discours
sur les algues vertes de créer un contre
discours de produire du doute en disant
ces algues vertes on ne sait pas
exactement d'où elles viennent en 2016
un deuxième plan algues vertes est
annoncée il est censé durer jusqu'en
2021 mais le 8 septembre de la même
année un joggeur est encore retrouvés
morts dans l'estuaire du gouessant
l'homme de 50 ans seraient décédés en
tentant d'aller au secours de son chien
pour les écologistes
le coupable se trouve à même le sol sur
cette affaire
rien n'a été fait pas de prise de sang
c'est simplement le top 6 après suite à
notre demande
or il aurait fallu que la prise de sang
soit fait comme quand il ya un accident
sur la route mais comme la famille du
mort le fait remarquer à quoi sert cette
autopsie puisque des semaines après le
décès il est plus possible de savoir
d'où provient l'hydrogène sulfuré
puisque le corps en putréfaction lui
même produit de l'hydrogène sulfuré
il ya un paradoxe qui surgit c'est que
le procureur de saint brieuc va dire au
terme de deux mois que aucun lien ne
peut être fait entre les algues vertes
et la mort de ce joggeur mais dans le
même temps il va demander aux mairies de
vraiment mettre des panneaux pour dire
que cet endroit l'estuaire du gouessant
est très dangereux quelques trois ans
plus tard le 6 juillet 2019
un ostréiculteur meurt brutalement dans
la baie de morlaix plusieurs
associations met de nouveau en cause les
algues vertes
mais une analyse poussée va écarter
cette théorie pourrait faiblir
en mètres carrés d'algues vertes
fraîches sur la plage on va tous mourir
pour arrêter ce délire a contrario faut
pas être dans la dénégation du fait que
si vous avez des granges à ma réaction
ça représente des riches le système de
ramassage mis en place n'arrivent pas à
venir à bout de ces algues vertes donc
les mairies sont obligés de fermer
certaines plages sur leur commune il ya
un an voix exceptionnelle de plage
fermée cette année en bretagne
et puis même les centres de retraitement
des algues vertes n'arrive pas à venir à
bout de ces algues vertes
ce qui fait que le centre de
retraitement par exemple de l'antique a
été obligé de fermer et que ces algues
sont dans les côtes d'armor répandue
dans les champs en fait pour que les
maths algues vertes diminue de moitié
il faudrait que dans les cours d'eau
bretons les taux de nitrate soit de 10
mg par litre d'eau or aujourd'hui ils
sont autour de 30 mg par litre d'eau et
on voit que ça fait des années et des
années que la bretagne dit on va
atteindre ces 10 mg par litre d'eau mais
il faut nous laisser plus de temps il
faut négliger des délais plus longs
et puis dernièrement la fnsea le
principal syndicat agricole a même dit
non mais en fait on a déjà pas mal
réduit les nitrates on est arrivé à 30
mg par litre d'eau donc peut-être que
maintenant on peut laisser les
agriculteurs tranquille cet été encore
les plages bretonnes sont envahies par
les algues vertes
certains endroits sont interdits d'accès
notamment dans la baie de saint brieuc
dans les côtes d'armor les plans de
lutte contre les algues vertes ont
permis de réduire la concentration en
nitrates dans les eaux bretonnes mais
pas suffisamment aux yeux des défenseurs
de l'environnement
l'association halte aux marées vertes a
d'ailleurs récemment lancé une nouvelle
pétition contre la prolifération de ces
algues elle réclame un changement
radical du modèle agricole breton
[Musique]